welcome back to Hannity tomorrow the UN
General Assembly is scheduled to vote on
a resolution opposing any recognition of
Jerusalem as Israel's capital this comes
after president Trump earlier this month
boldly announced his intentions to move
our embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
UN Ambassador nikki Haley is warning
that the US will be taking names and
today during a cabinet meeting President
Trump doubled down on ambassador Haley's
message take a look I like the message
that Nikki sent yesterday at the United
Nations for all of these nations that
take our money and then they vote
against us that the Security Council or
they vote against us potentially at the
Assembly
they take hundreds of millions of
dollars and even billions of dollars and
then they vote against us well we're
watching those votes let them vote
against us we'll save a lot we don't
care but this isn't like it used to be
where they could vote against you and
then you pay them hundreds of millions
of dollars and nobody knows what they're
doing so Nikki that was the right
message that you and I agreed to be sent
yesterday and I've had a lot of good
comment on it believe me people are
tired of the United States people that
live here are great citizens that love
this country they're tired of this
country being taken advantage of and
we're not going to be taken advantage of
any longer and joining us now is
Israel's ambassador to the United
Nations Danny Danon all right Danny I
love the idea of taking names I love the
idea of you know you're not going to do
this to us anymore but is it anyone's
business where the United States decides
to put its embassy in a foreign country
good evening judge the UN has no way to
tell Israel where the capital of Israel
should be and even have no way to tell
the US where to put the embassy of the
u.s. in Israel is that the audacity of
the UN must stop and I think tomorrow we
will see another session of bashing not
only of Israel bashing of the US and no
resolution that will pass can change the
reality that Jerusalem is as always will
be the capital of the state of Israel
you cannot change that you know so many
presidents are promised that they were
gonna do it what is it about this
president that I mean I
he's much stronger but but why would
they promise it and and not deliver what
was the harm to them were they afraid of
these other countries we see a different
kind of leadership and we appreciate
that it was a courageous bold decision
of President Trump and not only that
also the veto of ambassador Haley in the
Security Council last year I was in the
Security Council last December there was
another resolution in the previous
administration supported that shameful
resolution we see the change we
appreciate it this is a way to handle
the UN to come with your values with
your ideology and to change the UN we
need to reform the UN and and clearly
the president is going to do that he
talked about it with NATO and now he's
talking about it with the UN and but
what money that means there is there
money to individual countries that can
be impacted by you know the United
States saying you don't vote with us
we're not gonna give you money anymore
well that's for the president ambassador
heavy to decide about that but it's a
lot of hypocrisy in the UN and if you
give money to those countries I think
you should demand from them that's what
we do when we support countries I called
many ambassadors today and I told them
we support you we share technology cyber
security defense so now we need you to
more devote if you do not support us we
will also take notes why I mean even the
United Kingdom I mean you know there are
always supposed to be considered now
like why do they feel that they should
have a say as to where Israel has its
capital or the United States puts its
embassy they thing that they support the
peace process but exactly the opposite
they don't support the peace process
they support a Palestinian the ideology
of incitement of running away from a
dialogue the only way to move forward is
to have direct negotiations between the
Israelis and the Palestinians and the
president decision is the right move
because now that Palestinian understand
that with a new leadership they have to
decide whether the joining the
negotiations or we are moving on without
them and so I mean by by by saying that
you know this is going to disrupt the
peace process that's just their excuse
in fact it hasn't gone forward for a
long time maybe this is a way to do it
look what's happening in the last 20
years so many emissaries so many summits
nothing happened I think this is the
right approach and I think the president
will be engaged with the peace process I
think so anyway
thank you so much Jenny Jenny